In this unit I'm going to talk about how geometric objects are define for
rendering. Along the way I'll discuss points, and vectors and how these get used
in computer graphics. Let's dive right in, there are two distinctive
mathematical objects that we use in computer graphics all the time points, and
vectors. I'm going to focus on the 3D aspect since that's what we commonly use
3D computer graphics. Working in 2 dimensions is similar, 3D is just 50% more
interesting. To start, we'll define a 3D point as a location in space. A 3D
vector defines a direction in space. A location in space has to be defined with
respect to something else. For example on the earth we define a location in
terms of its latitude,longitude and altitude. This is a spherical coordinate
system, in that the lines of latitude and longitude wrap around a sphere, the
earth.